what's going on guys this is Rob and if
you're enjoying the content that I'm
uploading on my channel and feel free to
subscribe and you can also offer
suggestions on topics and characters and
storylines and whatnot that we can have
discussions on later on in this channel
so today I want to try something a
little bit different as we shift our
focus back to all-new all-different
marvel and DC rebirth or at least
emphasizing those videos or though that
content here on my channel I don't want
to forget about coming up with concepts
the series where we basically focus on
aspects of comic books that don't really
fit into a video on a particular story
arch so much as they're they kind of
exists in and of themselves and I want
to focus on the different colors of
Speed Force lightning within DC Comics
now you might have noticed if you read
flash comics that the various speedsters
in the DC Universe are often depicted as
being surrounded by lightening of
various colors and while sometimes it's
yellow sometimes it's also red blue or
even black and so in this video we're
going to try to explain why that is now
in order to do this we're gonna go look
at the comments made by Brett booth the
former artist for the flash and the
current artist for the DC rebirth Titan
series now of course you can find this
link down in the description but in a
post in the DC Comics sub reddit user
Stephen is awesome revealed that he had
spoken to booth via Twitter asking about
the different colors of lightning and
booth responded by saying the closer you
go to Lightspeed the more the colors
begin to shift and so while red is the
slowest blue and indigo are actually the
fastest by saying this what Brett booth
is doing is revealing that the Speed
Force Lightning exemplifies the
scientific phenomenon known as blue
shift no one would understand what this
means
we have to get scientific for a second
and basically explain the different
colors of light that our eyes are able
to receive so if you already know this
bear with before second while I went
over this for those who don't the first
thing to understand is basically
wavelength no wavelength refers to the
distance between the peaks of the
electromagnetic waves wavelength also
varies inversely with another concept
called frequency which is basically the
number of waves that pass a fixed point
in a certain amount of time
there is a little more to this than that
but that's pretty much all we need to
know for this particular discussion and
so the electromagnetic spectrum ranges
from waves with relatively long
wavelengths and low frequencies like
radio waves and microwaves all the way
to waves with extremely short
wavelengths like x-rays and gamma rays
and somewhere in the middle of all this
lies the small spectrum of ways that the
human eye can perceive as visible light
however even within visible light there
are variances in wavelength and
frequency of the various colors of light
with red having the lowest frequency and
violet having the highest and so what we
mean when we refer to blue shift is a
decrease in wavelength and an increase
in frequency with the red end of the
visible light spectrum towards the blue
end and so the question becomes why did
I explain all of this and how on earth
does it apply to the flashes lightning
well the roots of this lie in a Nerdist
article by a guy named Kyle Hill called
the flashes only red when he stands
still and this article Hill gives a
fairly detailed explanation of how the
flash itself as well as a lightning that
surrounds him changes color as the speed
approaches the speed of light for
instance if the flash travelled at 15%
of the speed of light he would appear
yellow which is further up the spectrum
than red if the flash speed increased to
thirty percent of the speed of light he
would appear green at 40 percent he
would appear blue and a 50% of the speed
of light the flash would appear violet
now all of this is assuming that your
eye could detect the color of an object
moving at that speed at all which it
couldn't as the brain's incapable of
processing images that fast but
regardless at any speed about 50% of the
speed of light the flash would enter
ultraviolet territory which is beyond
the visible spectrum for us to see
anyway know about out of the way we're
gonna shift back to what this means
about the flash in terms of comic books
during this discussion on reddit Bret
booth went on to say that the blue
shifting of the Flash's lightening
indicates not only that the flash is
simply moving faster but that he's
further trapped into the speed force now
for those of you guys who don't know
what the speed force is it's basically a
huge source of speed energy in the DC
Universe from which all speedsters
derive their powers so for instance when
we see Barry Allen in the earliest
stages of the new 52 universe he's
surrounded by red lightning and DC
rebirth however he's surrounded by
yellow lightning while many would likely
dismiss this as just an aesthetic design
choice if we take Brett Bruce
as at face value we see that this shift
is actually representative of the fact
that Barry is becoming more in tune with
the Speed Force which has enabled him to
run faster and cause his lightning to
shift further towards the blue end of
the spectrum booth also went on to say
that the Blue Lightning is a future
version Barry possessed in the
out-of-time story arc which booth worked
on along with Robert Venditti during
which time he was trapped further in the
Speed Force and is actually faster than
the present-day Barry Allen
no one asked about the black lightning
generated by professor zoom booth did
not divulge an explanation but he's at
some sort of reveal in the future but
with regards to the white lightning that
accompanies Wally West following his
return to the DC Universe and rebirth
booth seemed a hint that it could
indicate that this version of Wally is
able to speed up time which would lead
one to infer that this version of Wally
is actually faster than the current
version of Barry Allen this would also
make sense because Wally has spent a lot
of time inside the Speed Force since the
beginning of the new 52 universe so it
stands to reason that he would be able
to tap into it to a greater degree than
Barry Allen could and so this theory
holds up applying it to the most recent
flash story in which Barry Allen battles
a new villain named Godspeed during
their conflict we saw God's be
surrounded by white lightning after he's
stolen the Speed Force powers of several
speedsters that it received their powers
after a massive electrical storm in
Central City enhanced by the other
speedsters powers God speed
finds himself able to move faster than
Barry Allen who's still surrounded by
yellow lightning it's also worth
mentioning that the new 52 version of
Wally West who got his powers as a
result of the storm as well is depicted
with red lightning indicating that he's
not yet able to tap into the Speed Force
enough to travel as fast as Barry and so
with that being said what this basically
means is that you can determine the
speed of a speedster depending on what
color lighting they display but
something else to bear in mind this is
all coming from Bret booth himself which
also means that not all artists would
see things the same way he did but at
the very least this gives us an
indication of how the speed of the
various speedsters in DC Comics relates
to the color of their lightning and
helps us determine which one of these
speedsters is faster no with that being
said we're gonna bring this video to an
end if you guys are new here to the Rob
core make sure you guys drop a like make
sure you guys hit the sub button and
make sure you guys leave a comment down
below cuz I'm kind of curious which
speedster of all the speedsters that
have existed in DC
comics which speedster is your absolute
favorite and I will catch you guys later
peace
[Music]